-My first guests are both Emmy
winners and two of the funniest,
most talented people I know.
Gosh, I love them so much.
This is very exciting.
They've reunited as their iconic
characters Wayne and Garth
from "Wayne's World"
for a big Super Bowl commercial
for Uber Eats
airing this Sunday.
Look out for it.
It is really good.
Here is Mike Myers
and Dana Carvey.
Yeah!
-Whoo! Yeah!
Party on, Jimmy!
-Whoo!
-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
-Yeah, we're gonna come
and get some.
-Oh! Come and get some.
[ Laughter ]
-Come and get some right now.
-Oh!
It's good to have you guys here
to come and get some.
-I'm going to tour a character
I call Red Redneckie
the Redneck Comedian,
but I'm gonna hire
other comedians to play him.
"Alright, Redneck, I'm the Red
Redneckie, Redneck Comedian.
I know -- I know a redneck
married his sister,
only 'cause Mama
turned him down.
Come and get some."
"Come and get some"
is his catchphrase.
[ Laughter ]
"Come and get some."
The other day --
[ Laughter ]
"Come and get some" is
blowing up on my podcast.
-Come and get some.
-My kids and everyone
wanted to have some food.
I said, "We only have enough
hubcaps to go around
to feed everybody.
Come and get some."
[ Laughter ]
You should throw
"come and get some" --
-That was your turn to laugh?
-Yeah.
-Is that what that is?
-Yeah, come and get some
is everything. My grandpappy
invented the phrase
"dollars to doughnuts."
Every time he got a buck,
he bought a doughnut.
He died at 47.
Come and get some.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, "come and get some"
is the best thing.
-Oh, yeah!
-Oh, dude.
-Whatever, whatever, whatever
crap, you don't know
it gonna flersh
down that terlet.
Come and get some.
[ Laughter ]
It's just bad jokes, folks.
It's not supposed to be good.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Come and get some.
[ Laughter ]
-That's Red Redneckie
the Redneck Comedian.
You can see it here
on my podcast,
"Fantastic! with Dana Carvey."
-Come and get some.
-I have lots of questions
that I wanted to ask that
I've never asked you before.
-Really?
-Yeah. How long have
you known each other
and what do you remember each
about meeting each other?
Dana, you first?
-Oh. Michael and I met --
[ Laughs ]
I think -- I guess it was
the late '80s.
I'd done "SNL." I was fortunate
enough, freakily fortunate,
to get on "Saturday Night Live,"
and I was there for
a couple seasons I guess,
and then our latest new
cast member appeared,
and it was Mike Myers.
And I liked him right away.
He was a very, very clever lad,
and we, you know --
I think we just met around town
in the maelstrom of "SNL."
Just the most intense thing you
could ever experience, I think.
Mike?
-Yeah.
I hadn't seen the show
'cause I lived in England
and it wasn't on in England,
and then I moved to Canada
shortly, and I came into
what appeared to me
to be like this --
and it's true --
this all-star cast,
and just, like, "Oh, my God,
these guys are so fantastic,"
and then when I wrote
"Wayne's World,"
I just thought --
I mean, you know...
Dana Carvey was in my sketch
because just put good people
in your sketch and it'll get on,
you know, so.
-Well, the first few times
we went on,
we were kind of the last sketch.
-Yeah.
-I think it took us a while --
so it was like --
-The truth is, you were
in the area of the "SNL"
on the floor, you know,
where all sketches go to die.
That was where --
-Yes.
-The one all the way
far back on the left.
-Yes.
-The dead corner, yeah.
-The dead corner.
-That doesn't have an audience
looking at you at all.
They have to watch it
on the monitor.
-Yeah.
-And you're just like,
"Is anybody watching?"
You feel like you're sending it
out into space or something.
-Yeah. You broke the curse.
-And some planet will see it.
-We would jump up and down
with energy.
I think when you're last up
and you're over in the corner,
you're trying to be
kind of defiant.
Like, we'll just bring
psychotic energy.
"Wayne's --" Just screaming.
But eventually it caught on.
-And when you do these sketches,
you don't think
it's gonna be a film.
-No, we didn't think
it was gonna be a film,
and then when we did it,
we didn't think necessarily
they were gonna release it.
You know what I mean?
-Really?
-They were a little like,
"Hmm, what is this?"
You remember?
-Yeah, we didn't think they'd
bring actual cameras to the set.
We were young. We didn't know.
We weren't sure
if it was a stage play
or a puppet show at malls,
but anyway.
-But when did you feel like
it was a real movie?
'Cause it was
a giant, giant movie.
-That summer, I think.
Dana and I were invited to
this rally
that Ellen DeGeneres was hosting
at Lincoln Park in Chicago.
And one of the things
that struck me was that
Dana's the most relaxed
performer I'd ever --
First of all, it's just,
"Let's just have fun."
And I was like, "Oh, right,
we're supposed to enjoy this.
You're right." Because I'm a bit
of a tortured artist at times.
-I think we all are.
-I just wing it.
-We went out and he was like,
"Just have fun. Come on.
Let's do it."
And I was like, "You're not
really that person, are you?"
And he is really that person,
you know what I mean?
'Cause everyone always says
that, but --
And I was like, "Oh, right, I
don't have to be so tortured."
Still be present,
and you'd said something
that got a big, giant laugh.
And he was so calm that he --
it was like the "ahhh"
at Lincoln Park,
and he turned me and go,
"Do you want to eat at the hotel
or do you want to try
and find a place in Chicago?"
And I'd be looking at him
like...
-"We can't talk about that now!"
-"We're on stage.
Don't talk to me.
What are you doing?"
And he'd just wait it out
and then he'd be back in.
-Isn't it fun, though? 'Cause
even though you do have fun,
it is comedy, but putting all
that work into one little joke,
it could take you hours.
It could take you a week
to go,
"How are we gonna crack this?"
And then someone has to shake
you and go, "It's comedy.
Have fun." And you go,
"Right, right, right."
-Come and get some.
[ Laughter ]